he is a friend of mine uh works with the
nfl network reporter
huddle and flow podcast co-host steve
weish
joins us now to talk all things nfl
draft what's up steve how you doing
buddy
ryan man so great hearing your voice
hope all is well and i'm doing well i'm
here down at flowery branch with the
falcons so
things are exciting down here yeah talk
to me a little bit about that you know
it was announced about a month ago or so
that you were really gonna kind of
take a deep dive uh into the atlanta
falcons uh program and be around them
more often
how has that been and and are how are
you looking forward to it
well i mean that that's kind of cool you
know i'm still with the nfl network but
i'm going to be helping out with some of
their digital
and broadcast production stuff and also
help call the preseason games so
you know i'm kind of expanding my
bandwidth while also you know this
little extra
uh coverage of the falcons you know and
i'll be using this information on the
nfl network as well
so it's just kind of bringing more
attention to that ball club and
you know a lot of attention to the games
played in the southeast in the nfl
um you know because a lot of times they
get overshadowed you know all these
teams the titans
even the buccaneers you know saints
panthers teams like that they get
overshadowed when we talk about a lot of
the other teams in the nfl so me being a
presence here
a little bit more uh in atlanta um
will will hopefully shine a little bit
light a little bit more light on
on the football that's played down here
especially since the defending super
bowl champions played in the nfc south
yeah well a lot of light was shown on
that pick of theirs yesterday really the
first round hinged on a lot
of what they decided to do arthur smith
gets the new job this offseason
they decide to stick with matt ryan they
are always going to but there was talk
about taking a quarterback with a
a very uh you know deep quarterback
first round last night they decided to
go with probably the best all-around
player
in kyle pitts talk to us about their
decision making uh to take pits
and stay away from a quarterback there
in the first round
yeah you know when it came down to it
you know pits fit
what they want to do in a lot of
different ways as we know arthur smith
the new head coach
loves the tight end right we saw we did
in tennessee with johnny smith and
delaney walker
last year with anthony fercer and johnny
smith so here they've got hayden hurst
but now they add a darren waller
type player in pitch except pitch might
even be a better blocker than darren
waller so
you have you add that to calvin ridley
and
julio jones if he's going to be here
next season
and you've got a lot of offensive
potential to do some things
so you know we'll see what they do in
these later rounds to fix some of the
holes on defense but
they feel really confident that they've
got not only a dynamic
player but someone when you hear about
how he practiced and how he handles
himself in florida
really can help establish a culture that
establish a culture but
but kind of meld into the culture
they're trying to establish here
you brought up julio jones the
conversation got started a few days
before the draft
and because of the cap issues that the
falcons sit under
his name was brought into the
conversation around possibly being
moved out of there a a defense scheming
game changer for the atlanta falcons
uh now may be on the move where do you
think that sits right now and is it
something that
really still could be a possibility for
this team
oh it's real it it could really happen
you know from some folks i've talked to
here this is
these are conversations that continue
all the way up until training camp
you know and this is all stemming they
don't want to trade the player
right they know how great and impactful
the player is but their salary cap
is you know it's just so it's so
precarious right now i mean look they've
got to clear some space to even sign
their rookies
so when team started calling about julio
jones
they were like well this might be a way
to get some salary cap relief
and you know julio jones is great of a
player as he is he's been nicked and
he's 32
this might be the time when he's at his
greatest value to possibly bring some
future assets in return so again they
maybe
they try to work something out but as
long as people start you know
you know continue to call they're gonna
listen and you know you really get the
feel if if they get
an offer with all future picks that they
feel
can help eventually you know help them
eventually down the road
um you know julio could really be on the
move i mean i i this is this is very
serious this is very real
yeah it seems to be and and matt ryan
has to be quaking in his boots
uh with the thoughts of losing that
giant out
there uh you're locked in with all
things nfl
um the nfl draft of course was was a
huge deal last night but of cour
but a quarterback uh a reigning mvp
makes all the news
and the the stories that came out about
two hours before the draft
uh around aaron rodgers and uh
the disgruntled employee part of it and
not wanting to be a packer anymore and
the conversations around the broncos and
the 49ers
what do you what do you make of it all
and is this just a bunch of smoke once
again are we gonna see
aaron back in a green bay uniform or is
is this an actual threat that he's
willing to walk walk through
man i'm so glad he brought up aaron's
name because i thought you were going
down the tim tebow rabbit hole for a
minute there
[Laughter]
but but no i mean it seems it seems real
i mean this is
this is you know the fact that you know
brian gutenkos and the packers
leadership came out last night said
hey look we're working through some
things but we're not trading him
so i think you know what if it comes
down to it it comes down to a game of
chicken we're seeing aaron rodgers
decide if he wants to go back there and
be unhappy or if he wants to be the host
of jeopardy
because it doesn't sound in any way
shape or form that the packers are going
to move him relinquish his rights in any
way shape or form
and so maybe they you know they do
something with his contract
something to appease him but yeah i mean
look we know aaron has
has showed us this pleasure before but
the fact that this came out when it did
right before the draft um it was so
pronounced
and that it was very real uh goes to
show you they've
they've got some bridges to overcome and
that's just it's just so interesting how
we've had russell wilson and now aaron
rodgers and guys like this come out
and really show themselves publicly um
with some in-house business that that
typically is kept you know behind the
scenes
definitely and then and then though it's
just like a
a slap in the face they go and draft
another player that isn't on the side of
his
on on side of the football they have
never they have never once drafted
a player for him on the offensive side
of the football in the first round
except for one
last year jordan love and that certainly
wasn't for him
yeah that was that was the real that was
the real slap
uh in the face to him and of course he
says okay i'll show you and goes on and
wins the mvp with the speeches that they
have given him
and that seems like what they're saying
is like look he won the mvp
last year we almost got to the super
bowl um
do it again look there's been no
quarterback
in our generation this is talking to
coaches assistant coaches whomever
who has been asked to do more for his
team
individually with his athletic
performances at aaron rodgers
i mean he is asked to bail them out of
bad play calls
to win ball games for him to overcome
suspect defensive play
over and over so i
i think he's at the point of his career
saying you know i really don't need this
anymore you know i really don't need to
accomplish any more on a football field
so let me flex a little bit i love the
game but you know
if i have to leave it i'm good i've got
other options
what was the biggest what do you think
the biggest we're talking with steve
weiss from the nfl network
uh what do you think the biggest
surprise was
uh last night in the nfl draft um
was it the the eagles move was it the
the bears making the big jump for justin
fields
where where did you see the biggest
surprise from last night
well clearly to a bunch of people who
fell for the okie doke
it was the 49ers taking trey lance when
so many people thought they were taking
matt jones
i mean this this was so beautifully
played
by the 49ers how just not dispelling any
of the mac
jones conversation really playing into
it when ryan you know i spoke to people
it you know did
i ever even reported it like you know
two weeks ahead of time
saying look i'm speaking to people on
the league who say they're telling me
it's not going to be mac jones i mean
and you know they were suggesting that
they really really loved
tree land they were doing a lot on him
turned out to be that
but it's just amazing how once you know
a couple reports came out about the mac
jones thing how it just created this
landslide and nobody was talking about
him being a top five player until the
niners made that trade
and the fact that they it created that
much hysteria and then on draft night
they're like no
we're taking trey lance you know i think
that really you know i don't think it
necessarily changed the draft pecking
order that much
um but i i do think that was probably
the biggest public surprise that there
was
yeah i think a lot of people were i and
to your point i think people just had
bought into the idea that
mac jones all of a sudden was going to
be anointed the king
by uh by you know kyle shanahan when
you know he he was not no one out there
anywhere
had prescribed to him as a top five pick
so the fact that
it played out on national tv like he
dropped to the patriots at 15
is absurd i think it was a perfect place
for him to go and
and bill pelicek has got to be a happy
camper right now
with uh um what i would consider tom
brady light coming out of college
um to be their next uh franchise
quarterback
absolutely you know he is loving this
right now they didn't have to move for
him
he fell right to him he's going into a
situation where they've added so many
pieces
this off season you know he's going to a
culture that can be very similar to what
he had was saving down
alabama so you know the page that you're
like this is great but now they're going
to start pressuring him
just like he had to go through to
alabama to come out and deliver
and he didn't necessarily have to come
out right away man he was the third
string quarterback you know for for
a long time so i liked how it played out
um
uh before we get you out of here let's
talk a little bit about
what the falcons do next today is of
course round twos and three
they have pick number 35. i i
i liken them to do something at the
quarterback position to
ultimately you know at a point take over
for matt ryan maybe in a year or two uh
is there a quarterback you think that
that falls into that place
either for them in round two or round
three that they could reach for
yeah i mean you know look i i may be
more so around three you know we'll see
if there's the run on quarterbacks but
you look
but who's remaining and and that's the
you know the offensive line
a lot of talent there but they really
have got to find some help on defense so
i think
if you you know you look with that third
pick in the second round someone like
aziz ogilari the
the edge player from georgia who's
played in a kind of a flex 34 scheme
which d
p's is going to run here that can be an
option
j okay the linebacker out of uh notre
dame the buckets award winner
he could be an option even maybe a
corner like an asante samuel
i'm not going to rule out though uh
running back you know javonte williams
out of north carolina they want to add
an explosive running back to pair with
mike davis
we'll see if they continue to go offense
but at some point they're going to have
a quarterback matt ryan is the only one
under contract
so i think when the quarterbacks start
going if maybe they go mid-round
they use that fourth pick in the third
round that they have and trade up
to maybe go get into into that company
to possibly draft a quarterback
yeah i i like uh i like a young man out
from out west here davis mills i think
he would be
very a very good fit yeah a very good
fit in that offense
steve i appreciate you taking the time
best of luck enjoy the second and third
and rest of the weekend
of the nfl jeff always good to talk to
you my friend
my man best to you ryan you bet steve
weish
nfl network huddle and flow podcast does
it with jim trotter
old beat writer for the chargers when i
was in san diego
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here